se incrementa la escalada de violencia
entre israelíes y palestinos los civiles
son los más afectados los 50 bombardeos
de este domingo en la madrugada en gaza
por parte del ejército de israel y
dejaron al menos 33 muertos en 15
minutos destruyeron varias
construcciones de la ciudad incluyendo
la casa del líder del movimiento hamás
ya ya así igual quien no se encontraba
en su vivienda en ese momento los
bombardeos israelíes se produjeron en
simultáneo con el lanzamiento de cohetes
desde gaza según un portavoz militar
israelí se registraron más de 130
disparos cifra que eleva a 2900 los
proyectiles lanzados a su territorio
desde el inicio de la actual escalada
bélica según la fuente unos 450 cohetes
han caído dentro del enclave y unos
1.150 han sido interceptados por el
sistema antimisiles israelí actualmente
varios equipos trabajan en el rescate de
las personas atrapadas bajo los
escombros de varios edificios
residenciales derribados en gasa con
excavadoras intentan remover los
escombros para sacar a los
sobrevivientes atrapados y los cuerpos
de los que murieron
hay un hombre vivo nuestro equipo habló
con él y nos dijo que está vivo el
equipo lo sacará y esperamos que su
hermana también esté viva y podamos
sacarla
tanto israel como el grupo hamas han
insistido en continuar los ataques un
día después de que israel destruyera un
edificio de 12 pisos en gaza que
albergaba medios de comunicación
internacionales la ola de ataques
israelíes de este domingo ha sido la
mayor desde hace siete días cuando
empezaron los enfrentamientos